[Applaus]
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sport rapport
dem sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers mein name ist andreas sohn
er ich bin selbst heraus sportler und
heute zu gast zum sportwart andreas graf
rennradfahrer herzlich willkommen du
hast eine spannende geschichte hinter
dir wie du zu deinem radsport gekommen
ist und das was du machst du bist der
bahn und rennradfahrer du bist du dann
zum radfahren bekommen ja ich bin eher
unorthodox radsport kommen in meiner
gemeinde war 1996 radrennen und auf der
großen kreuzung wurde jeden tag vorbei
kann und bin über großes plakat auf das
klingt unlizenzierten nach ländern auch
für kinder und ihr wollt unbedingt
teilnehmern von meiner familie hat mit
dem spitzensport egal in welchen sport
niemand was zu tun gehabt dann bin ich
rausgegangen und sagte meine eltern sehr
gern an diesen radrennen teilnehmen
natürlich auch man kann also nichts
gehabt dann haben wir hinter gemeinden
müssen wir aber in graz haben wir uns
aus parkt bin dann alleine zu den start
fahren
du musst zwar formular ausfüllen wo
natürlich dann allerdings berechtigte
schreiben musste aber eine wieder mit
minz dann aber den zettel bin mit meinem
fahrrad wieder heimfahren auch bitte
unterschreiben sonst kann ich nicht
starten
dann hat das unterschrieben dann bin ich
wieder hin gibt in wilster habe man die
startnummer drauf kräfte und auf die
plätze fertig los
und nach 20 minuten gewonnen gehabt
es war eigentlich der grundstein für
meine erkläre wohl noch mal dann ist
erst mal gedanken gemacht habe es macht
eigentlich spaß der sport und zum glück
ist dann aus bottendorf verein auf mich
zukommen sagt könnte sein dass du talent
hast und was ihr spaß macht willst du
bei uns im verein beitreten und zwar
jetzt ein bissel mehr hinfahren wo es
bestand das talent ich meinen also was
er damals zehn jahre also kann man das
irgendwie benennen kann man nicht
benennen nehmen darf ist das fahrwerk
setzt ich gewusst dass ich morgen nicht
wie die scheidung funktioniert mit
draufsetzte eintreten und das erste über
die ziellinie gefahren
also ich weiß nicht was ich gemacht habe
ich halt einfach gut gegangen und dann
hast einfach angefangen im verein mit zu
trainieren die kann man sich das
ungefähr vorstellen
wie laura training geben im nachwuchs
hat das gute war dass der verein eben
seine nachwuchsfahrern sehr unterstützt
hat der verein hat für kinder radschuhe
fahrradhelm und alles gehabt weil ihr
kind so wie ich orden hat nichts gehabt
und wir haben es zur verfügung gestellt
bekommen was er da große finanzielle
unterstützung für alle kinder ist und
dann haben wir sogar einmal in der woche
ein freies training gehabt am wochenende
eine längere ausfahrt und in der nähe
von bondorf aus rüben platz damals
technik drin gehabt wie schaltet man
richtig wie wechsele man reifen und
lauter zu suchen und in der gruppe hat
ist natürlich der neue spaß gemacht wenn
man immer so zwischen 25 und 30 kinder
in den verein und das kriegt mit denen
wir uns selbst habe ich und wie läuft
das training konkret habe ich meinen du
hast da sowohl bahn als auch straßen
rennrad fahren muss man sich dafür
entscheiden dafür oder macht man einfach
beides oder wird euch das im nachwuchs
macht man beides ich hab den
leistungsgedanken im radsport war bei
mir ganz hinten angestellt jetzt einfach
macht weil freunde von mir dort waren
aber dass man spaß gemacht hat und ich
war im nachwuchs bei gott nicht gut ich
bin halt irgendwo im mittelfeld mit
gefahren und habe mir leid dass sie
meine ganzen freunde sich mit der zeit
verbringen kann
das ist erst viel viel später kommt man
erst als junior oder man eigentlich bin
ich nicht schlecht wenn ich mir jetzt
bisschen rein haben uns auf das
konzentrieren könnte da vielleicht ein
schritt nach vorne machen damen in
österreich irgendwo mit fallenden kursen
und aber dass sie irgendwann an die
weltspitze erreichen das aber nicht
gedacht und wie ist der prozess gewesen
dass du dann angefangen hast dich damit
auseinanderzusetzen fortschritte gesehen
im training oder die gleiche ergebnis
war die ergebnisse eben daneben aus 13
15 und 17 fahrer im mittelfeld fahren
und dann bin ich zur junioren
aufgestiegen und tabak körperliche
entwicklung gemacht über vor allem
relativ klein und dann auf ein wenig
wachsen und aber aber man kriegt und
dann als junior samt begonnen rennen zu
gewinnen und märkten gewinne macht
einfach spaß hatten im mittelfeld und
das mit die freunde sondern ist als
erster die ziellinie forst holz das er
dann auch eine ausbildung gestartet und
du bist elektroinstallations- techniker
wie hat das funktioniert du hast
trotzdem dann mit dem rad fahren weiter
gemacht der arbeit trainieren wie
erstklassig also geschichte das
elektriker gelernt habe war kommt auch
ein bisserl weiter her weil ich wollte
unbedingt in die südstadt gehen weil man
trainer aus dem verein sagt gehen die
schule in der schulstadt da kannst du
sport und kombinieren und meine eltern
hatten mich sport überhaupt nichts zu
tun kann man sagen dass wir es mit der
ausbildung
sie sind herr schmidt der castings
machen der praktische ausbildung und so
ist moxa lehre und dann aber noch viel
lernen und sport das ist wären jetzt
vater drei jahre und dann hingesetzt und
solange gesucht bis es war kleine
elektro firma gefunden habe sie gesagt
hat ja sie finde es toll was sie machen
und war auf trainingslehrgängen oder
eineinhalb würden sind wir frei gegeben
ungeteilt und die muss die zeit hat dann
nach meiner lehre noch dranhängen
und dann hat man sagt okay das ist jetzt
die möglichkeit den nächsten dreieinhalb
jahre haben wir schwere jetzt immer
durchbeißen und es war kein leichter
zeit aber in der zeit habe ich ja so in
meinem kopf gehabt dass sich sport
weiter kann man will dann passt hat
jetzt ein halle durch scheitern so und
bis dann auch relativ schnell auch zum
herzsport dazu gekommen
oder hast doch dann gehe ich als
elektriker gearbeitet nach der lehre nur
die zeit was sie dann die was man
gewählt hatten müssen habe und sobald
der tag vorbei war war es aber vorbei
und dann bin ich direkt in telfs
patienten kommen und dann mit einer
kurzen unterbrechung bis jetzt im her
dass sport setzungen das sehr
erfolgreich auf 14 staatsmeistertitel
europameister 2014 gesamtweltcupsieger
2018 im doppel
was ist das doppel das ist kein tandem
oder wie kann man sich da die disziplin
genau vorstellen dass katar erfahren
jeder für sich einer von uns ist mein
rennen und der andere kann sich
sozusagen oben ausrasten bis der nächste
kommt und dann macht man so man kann
sich vorstellen wie händchenhalten also
ein schneider griff so weil man mit
einem kind links und rechts gehen und so
eines der hauptopfer macht gehen auch so
waren wir kommen und nehmen mein partner
und schlager denen ins rennen
durch das ist das land heute extrem
schnell
was du immer ausgelassen ins rennen
kommst und dann bist nur für 20 sekunden
im rennen und das hat wieso naja wie es
ein staffellauf und das war auf der bahn
das ist die achterbahn ja und in der
disziplin ist ja auch schon qualifiziert
wie war das mit der qualifikation bei
der weltmeisterschaft bei der
weltmeisterschaft das war eher ein
rennen wo man jetzt so leicht man dann
halt aber wir haben hier auf das
weltmeisterschafts rennen konzentrieren
können weil für uns oberste priorität
war dass wir uns für dunkle
qualifizieren und werden bewusst dass
der platz dem ich sehe es aber warum
stürzen oder auswahl haben dnf stehen
und mit dem nullpunkt am ende und die
anderen nationen hat die 56 hinter uns
waren gut fahren dass uns die überholen
können und durch die savanne auf
sicherheit gefahren wo massiv
durchkommen das ergebnis bei der wm hat
dann in deutschland aber wir haben die
olympia quali in dem sinne was auf lange
sicht auch zählt jetzt stelle ich mir
vor dass es so schwierig ist sich sowohl
auf bahnrennen und und auf straßen
rennen zu konzentrieren wie schafft man
das liebling das unter die letzten jahre
ist es für mich ganz gut gegangen ich
hab die sechstagerennen und als im
winter gehabt dann habe ja keine pause
gemacht
nach der bahn-wm immer und bin erst
später in den straßen saison
eingestiegen
ich war immer in österreichischen
continental team auf ihrer tour level
unterwegs und ganz seltener
kapitänsrolle dort gehabt sie ja durch
eine lange erfahrung habe ich immer
irgendwelche führungspositionen gehabt
und die teams geleitet und kann so nicht
immer ganz vorne um spitzenergebnisse
mit fahren kannst oder musst kannst du
dir immer ein bisschen schonen und zur
spd ist straßenversion immer gut
durchkommen auf der straße dann heute
zurück stellt meiner eigenen ergebnisse
an zwar einen im jahr
dann würde jetzt gerne auf mich fahren
wahrscheinlich mal in anspruch genommen
und bin ja relativ gut voran aber dann
habe ich mich dann hauptsächlich
verdienst von meiner mannschaft gestellt
weil mein absoluter fokus die mannschaft
haben wir also taktisch fahren um
energie zu sparen oder sinnvoll
zu fahren damit man da noch der bahn
erfolgreich sein kann also auch da eine
gute strategie wie kann man sich das
training im hochleistungs radsport
verstehen ich mal müsst ihr gewaltige
umfänge am rad und auf der walze und
rennrad selbst absolvieren sie können
sich das vorstellen
er ist es ja ganz unterschiedlich
welcher blogger gehört ist weil man das
waren richtigen ausdauer block groß am
anfang von einer saison hat verbringst
du wirklich sehr sehr viel zeit monaten
heute am fahrrad dass wir fliegen man
immer irgendwo im süden oder so weil es
hat gerade so in den wintermonaten ist
und dort von einer gruppe geht es dann
doch was dann so um 25 30 wochenstunden
kommst ist schon sehr sehr viel zeit was
man fahrrad verbringen die zeit vergeht
hat danach noch mehr zu schnell aber man
sondern zu spannen dabei phasen kommst
wo es dazu ganz hochintensive sachen
hast vergeht die zeit wie im flug und
durch das wiegt sie das wird immer auf
und das macht es immer spaß bringen
kannst du nicht beziffern wie viele
kilometer da so in einer
vorbereitungszeit fahren muss kann die
jahres kilometer sagen gekommen so plus
minus 7 was auf 30.000 im schnitt ein
wein sind als man sich vorstellt dass
man also ein paar hundert kilometer hat
stellt man sich als normal sportler
sportlerin schon anstrengen hut ab das
ist sicher auch für unsere
trainingsleistung enorm intensiv was
fasziniert dich jetzt nach den vielen
jahren in dem jetzt schon aktiv bist am
radsport dass das immer noch so intensiv
auf dem level betreibst die komponente
dass du halt immer mit anderen leuten
fest dass dort wirklich absolut nicht
vorhersehen kannst wie der einfall auf
wird weil jeder von uns eigentlich
gedanken hat und dass anleihen vorstellt
und das versucht er dann so gestalten
und du musst immer irgendwie eine
antwort finden und so oder auch selbst
irgendwie reagieren agieren das hat das
spannende vor allem an banker sport aber
so schnell weg ist weil man halt nicht
nur 250 meter
du hast natürlich lebenszeit muss sehr
intuitiv handlung und das sehr schnell
und das hat das spannende am radsport
für mich aber das heißt auch dass fehler
relativ schnell
nicht verziehen werden können wie gehst
du mit solchen situationen um brender
mal passiert dass man taktisch schlecht
weiter selbst gerade passiert immer
wieder mehr selbst vor kurzem basiert
die war immer hinterher und habe dass
wir ihm immer meine eigenen fehler
ausbessern müssen werden die anderen
wieder akzente setzen haben können und
irgendwann geht damit dann die power aus
von deiner eigenen fehler ausbessern
es gibt rein was gut läuft gibt eine
schlecht kraft die muss dann hinsetzen
videoanalyse machen oder auch wichtig
ist dass die fehler erkennst dass das
weiß dass das zunächst einmal immer man
abhaken und nach vorne schauen
wie funktioniert die zusammenarbeit mit
seinem doppelpartner andreas müller wie
kann man sich das vorstellen muss man
gemeinsam trainieren muss man sich da
abstimmen oder kann man beliebig sich
abwechseln mit dem man doppel fährt kann
man sich nicht abwechseln speziell die
weltmeisterschaften profitieren wir
heute schon darauf dass wir 2008 ein
standardsatz an standard teams sein und
immer gemeinsam fahren sie was von
seiner körpersprache her oder wir haben
fahrrad sieht ganz genau können wir
jetzt attackieren kann man jetzt noch
was drauflegen
oder ich besser schon jetzt das ist sehr
wichtiger part und das sehr großer passt
wo es uns unseren ganzen weg begleitet
dass wir unsere vorbilder verlassen
können aber wir müssen jetzt nicht
gemeinsam trainieren oder so wir könnten
trainieren es gibt viele paare die
verstehen sie privat überhaupt nicht ich
verstehe man zuerst mit glück sehr gut
und wir haben also kleine wohnung in new
york gemeinsam und man hat immer
gemeinsam im winter verbringen und
trainieren und sehr sehr viel zeit
gemeinsam trainieren
also ich sage dass das wirklich küche
ist dass wir zwei uns gefunden haben so
gut harmonieren sportlich welche
faktoren sind da und auch wichtig also
nicht nur dass das man vielleicht privat
anschneidet nicht kompatibel sein muss
als natürlich gut aber muss man schauen
dass man gleich große ist dass man die
gleichen hebel hat oder das oder das
jeder verschiedenen stärken hat die man
dann ein bringt das gibt es auch dinge
die man bei der beide partner auswahl
vielleicht auch beachten muss
das nicht nur weil eben relativ groß
damit ist jetzt so groß dass man jetzt
mit vielen sehr wichtig ist halt dass
die ablöse sehr gut funktioniert und
eben das zusammenspiel im rennen das
ungefähr die gedanken gleich sein weil
das bringt jetzt nichts weil ich ganz
aus dem rennen denken müssen attackieren
wir brauchen punkte und also denkt
person mehr warten noch mehr warten auch
am morgen es am schluss also du musst ja
ungefähr die gleiche richtung denken
beim rennen das im endeffekt ein kurzer
gruß aus er kommt sehr spannend also was
man alles beachten muss es einfach so
dass das fahrrad nicht gleich fahrrad
ist
die räder sind ja alle verschieden zu
dem was wir vielleicht als fahrrad
erkennen wie wie ist es mit einem bahn
rennrad wie wie kann man sich das
vorstellen
bei meinem rennrad fehlt praktisch alles
also es hat zwar zwei laufend erfordert
als ein interesse an lenker pedale
aber das war es dann schon mehr haben
keine bremsen werden keine gangschaltung
wir haben keine trinkflaschen unserer
fahrrad ist übersetzt das heißt wir
können nie aufhören zum treten wir
verlegen unsere geschwindigkeiten ins
spiel mit der bahn und mit ein bisschen
zu rückwärts pusht kannst da rausnehmen
aber dass jetzt auch voll bleiben sind
das womacks das war funktioniert hat
nicht jetzt hat dann meistens von vor
der sturz basiert versuchst du entweder
auf einer linie übernahmepreis oder
fliegt darüber
und das aber auch eben gefährlich dafür
ist ein geschwindigkeiten jeder hat sind
die enormen es passiert ja auch immer
wieder etwas das dann auch sehr
glimpflich ausgeht hoffentlich oder auch
mit schweren verletzungen dann die
sportler zu bleiben ist auch etwas was
man im kopf hat wenn man fährt das im
endeffekt sofort immer irgendwas
passieren kann dass man komplett
ausgeblendet also mal überstürzen
überhaupt noch nie gedanken gemacht
ich muss sagen zum glück bin ich meiner
karriere von einbrüchen verschont
blieben ja bis jetzt nur abschürfungen
an das schwere prellungen gehabt auf
einen knochenbruch natürlich einer der
wenigen die so durch gut durch kommentar
aber ich habe mal wenn er als fahrer
steht dass er einfach keine gedanken
darüber machen was könnte passieren wenn
ja das muss man aussprechen da muss man
professionell genug sein also auch die
mentale stärke haben dass man sich dann
nicht auf dienste negativer fokussiert
das vielleicht passieren könnte man auch
das enorm wichtig gibt es dinge die man
beim fahrrad selber irgendwie keine
ahnung noch verbessern kann damit man
dann noch leichteres rad oder oder von
material oder sind im endeffekt waren
alle mit dem gleichen rad und da gibt es
vom material her keinen großen vorteil
den man sich irgendwie arbeiten es gibt
immer wieder vorteile im aatal wahrheit
die techniken stehen bleibt die
forschung geht immer weiter immer so
halbwegs aerodynamik-tests wo wir um und
umbauen bin und das ist nun mal mein
steckenpferd also sehr gerne fahrräder
basteln das eine oder andere mal bin ja
schaut disqualifizieren weil mein vater
dann nicht ganz den vorschriften
entsprochen hat weil ich den lenker
abgeschnitten habe und dann selbst
wieder die carbon laminate gemacht habe
es macht sinn dass die regel gibt das
man machen soll war der lenker sehr
wichtiger teil ist und dann noch gibt
aber wenn man ziemlich sicher dass es
hält und dass sie eine dynamische am
fahrrad sitzt man besser machen
aber ja an der position vom lenker oder
die wir auf einem fahrrad auffliegen das
haben sehr wichtige komponenten die in
versierter sehr viel zeit weil es halt
einfach mehr benefit ist inter gewinnen
kannst also die zeit investierst weil
jetzt zum beispiel 30 oder 40 watt nur
mit der dynamik zu finden
dann musst du richtig viel zeit
investieren ins training wenn sie
überhaupt noch möglich ist sie in diesem
bereich zu steigern im spitzenbereich
und das ist wahrscheinlich dann auch
etwas was alle anderen im training
genauso machen und wahrscheinlich es ist
im training ausgeglichen und angepasst
das niveau als wenn man dann versucht
über die technik noch vorteile zu holen
auch das sehr interessanter aspekt du
hast auch den spitznamen prinz wohl aber
graf heißt wie es dazu gekommen
da waren wir sehr jungen und habe den
sprung ins nationalteam geschafft und
war mit jedem fahrer unterwegs und so
eigentlich immer schon die arrivierten
fahrer fläche und die haben wir dann
irgendwann
wir müssen den spiel zu finden und dann
ist ja nichts eingefallen und an einem
tag ist im betreuer auto vom nationalen
betreuer an die tschechische speicherung
navigieren die zehn hinterhergefahren
und die also unseren alle angeschaut wie
wir fahren und am ende des trainings hat
sie gesagt der dass der hübsche stella
das ist das schönste am fahrrad ihrer
meinung nach heute und auch noch
natürlich geklagt und einen so ist
finster entstanden und das hast du auch
gerne angenommen dass sodann der print
sowas ist habe gerne angenommen und
mittlerweile ist so dass viele von den
jungen fahrern nehmen wir wissen wer der
graf ist sondern viele glauben es ist
mal ein richtiger name war mir einfach
gehen damit in sachen spricht
mittlerweile das heißt es ist mir
geblieben wie waren die ganzen
auswirkungen der pandemie auf oder
wettkämpfe wie hat sich das war ich
ausgewirkt in vielen sportarten ist er
fast der sport grundlegend verändert
worden
und die ganzen abläufe wie war das bei
euch nun hier bei uns was auch von einem
tag auf den anderen ist dann halt alles
abgesagt worden also gar keine beine
mehr und wir haben einen schönen
frühling kenner auf trainingslager und
so haben wir ein kurzes um gedanken
machen müssen
im radsport hat dann dieses umdenken auf
diesen sport gegeben
also ich bin jetzt kein großer ist wenn
ich vor die rennen aber ich denke
trotzdem dass hatte ich dieses wort auf
der straße ein mann gegen mann
stattfindet und nicht jeder in seinem
wohnzimmer der kindle in einer
leistungsdiagnostik zentrum gehen jeder
fordern stufen test center irgendwo hin
und sagen den besten stufen test gewinn
ich glaube noch immer dass demokratie
eben diesen mann zu mann und die
praktische komponente einer der
wichtigsten ist und die wird in dieser
serie unterschätzt aber durch eben durch
die iren in dieser zeit haben wir die
möglichkeit gehabt und sei irgendwie zu
messen war sehr wichtig ist im training
schon nach fünf sechs wochen ohne ziel
dann war eine große anzahl die nächsten
rennen
aber das merkt irgendwann du stagniert
weiterhin fast dann hinter maria und das
was draufsteht
aber nehmen wir somit den letzten biss
der halt da ist und wir dann so im
herbst reihen wieder die runden kommen
und wieder
die europameisterschaft mit seiner
weltcup rennen und ich habe wieder
allerdings ehrgeiz gestiegen also das
war schon eine harte zeit
spitzensportler denke also jetzt haben
wir für mich ich glaube das war für alle
sehr schwer und die rennen selbst sind
dann stattfinden konnten
normalerweise hat man ja bei euch
zuschauer die die euch anfeuern ob jetzt
auf der straße oder im band stadion wie
wir das wenn dann plötzlich die leere
halle die man einfach ab fährt ohne halt
unterscheidet also das ist so beim
aufwärmen und rundherum war ich ja ganz
anders weil es ja immer vor wettkämpfen
zusammen und der nächste atmosphärischer
war aber im rennen selbst so war dann
sowohl man tun und abendlicher weise
überhaupt nicht wahrgenommen da habe ich
gemerkt dass ich mich so auf seine
konzentriert dass sie nicht mehr kommt
da viele zuschauer sahen die jetzt
brünen oder weniger oder im service
jetzt gar keine
aber der größte unterschied war schon
beim aufwärmen und so passt ja wann da
irgendwelche rennens an und sie schreien
und so und vom team her beim werden uns
selbst was egal für mich jetzt
persönlich das ist auch die spots rennen
kurz angesprochen wie wie läuft das
genau die kann sich das vorstellen
jeder hat zu hause sein fahrrad in so
einem heimtrainer eingespannt über den
werden die aktuellen was die du
produzierst ermittelt und es wird durch
dein gewicht gerechnet und dann mit
seiner formel umgerechnet und dann
vorerst noch heute virtuell am
bildschirm die avatare gegen also
doppelt mit eingerechnet wer in diesem
spiel wirklich gut ist also wenn du
länger fast bis auf einem höheren level
dann kann dann aber da bessere kurven
fahren also wie man ein level 1 bist und
naja das hat ich sage es ist wie ein
computerspiel das ist wirklich spiel
komponente ist es nicht reiner
leistungsvergleich sondern wie genau da
spielen das ist sehr spannend da die
technologie nimmt doch da entwicklungen
mit sich
verrätst du deine wattzahlen die du so
betreten kannst ist das etwas was man
sagt oder tief in das team und mich
neulich sah ich habe so es gibt eine
plattform der star war
da werden da eine ganze strecken was du
fährst aufzeichnet ich veröffentlich
meine ganze strecken jeder kann schauen
was sie trainieren wie viel waren
weil die durchschnittsrate sagen jetzt
wenig aus über deine leistung also ich
habe aktuell habe ich irgendwo war
schwerer so bei 380 und wann ich
wirklich gut bin ich spiele so auf 420
also es sind schon einige die da
zusammen bringt die wir noch ganz kurz
in dann in eine private zeit ich habe
hier deine hobbys stehen tun gehen
wandern skifahren sonst bist du nicht
nur im rat auch gerne draußen beim
training und eben nicht beim beim
sporteln
was gibt dir das wenn du in der natur
all diese dinge machen kannst
ich bin generell gerne draußen die natur
mensch aber wann ist man den wald gehen
weiter und so heißt die ganzen geräusche
und du bist allein also jetzt beim
wandern gibt man irgendwie so ruhig wie
kann zu mir finden und gibt es manchmal
freundin die sehr gerne mit mir bei
anderen geht wir wollen in waldeck ein
bisschen kali kann direkt vom haus auf
die hohe wand gehen oder auf dem man
dass man euch so 45 stunden wanderungen
wo es wirklich die natur die ruhe
genießen kannst zehn minuten von der
wirtschaft weg und es ist
mucksmäuschenstill zuerst den wald
rauschen daher ist die vögel zwitschern
und im winter beim tourengehen finde ich
sehr spannend wie sie dieser landschaft
verändern kann
du gehst unten weg dass man sonnenschein
dann erst durch nebel durch sich nichts
mehr
und gestern auch stück weiter auf und da
um hass breit sonnenschein das ist nun
also die weißenberg gefahr aus also mir
persönlich gibt es sehr viel veränderung
ist auch in deinem auto ein thema wer
denkt etwas zu sein hat aufgehört etwas
zu werden also anscheinend ein stetiges
weiterarbeiten ein stetiges wachsen ist
dir das richtig das ist mir sehr wichtig
denken wahrscheinlich bislang was für
die meisten leistungssportler allem
einer medaillenerfolge was ihr haupt
liegt alles im keller bei mehr in sack
und wann ist sie umgehend creek auf dem
podest und bei den fotos aktionen danach
müsse weg weil einfach diese erfolge für
mich logisch waren hart dafür gearbeitet
die viel investiert und dann ist das
rennen dann bin jetzt viel weltmeister
euro
meister proper und alle haben sich
gefreut
doch warum freuen sie da jetzt das für
mich ist es logisch also jeweils etwas
investiert was ich gemacht habe und dann
nehme ich meine medaillen und links
unten im keller hin nirgends erreicht
schön aber im fokus sofort auf meinen
neuen zielen
und ich glaube dass das sehr wichtig ist
was viele dann machen wenn sie eben ist
erst einmal großes also jetzt mehrmals
sehen ja erst einmal großes sportliches
ziel erreicht haben dann freuen die so
dass sie diese erreicht haben und wissen
nicht warum und wie einer fehlt dann der
weitere schritt und das versuche mit
denen komplett weg zum regen das sie
erreicht aber mir war es klar weil genau
gewusst was investiert haben wir das
gemacht habe und wie kann jetzt zum
nächsten schritt kommen wir nicht weiter
kommen das war immer schon bei mir
irgendwie es war treibende kraft im
hintergrund also es keine angelernte
technik oder methode sondern so bist du
halt was wären denn die nächsten ziele
wenn du sagst einfach immer weiter
nächstes ziel diagnosen ziel ist
natürlich olympia und vor zwei wochen
war es jetzt aber mein partner
zusammengesetzt und gesagt was kann man
wirklich erreichen und wir sagen top 5
ist unser ziel und war man im perfekten
tag haben wir kommen in der besten form
hin in der vorbereitung hat alles passt
jetzt haben wir eine medaille ist
definitiv möglich müssen im weltcup
schon mehrmals aufs podium fahren
während den gesamtweltcup zum
matchwinner beim europameister und da
ist in dieser disziplin also um andere
metalle ist definitiv möglich und über
die spiele hinweg
was bringt die zukunft was die zukunft
will übrigens 36 muss man dann auch ein
bisschen neu orientieren
hier habe vor zwei jahren eine kleine
tochter krieg kommt darauf an in welchem
vertrag über ein verein nächstes jahr
krieg und es ward ausschaut
ich werde definitiv weiterfahren war es
nochmal genau welchen label oben runter
steigt wobei keine wm mehr vor oder ob
wir so weiter machen aber das ist
schauen wir mal für olympia läuft und
dann auch
es gibt auf jeden fall genug aktivitäten
was mich noch interessiert kann sich
vorstellen zurück in einen elektriker
beruf irgendwann mal also jetzt nicht
die nächsten jahre irgendwann einmal
wieder
lexika zu sein oder da was zu machen
oder hat gelernt damit das heißt jetzt
gelernt dass ich mache aber es wird
schwer dass sie wieder das elektrische
zurückkommen weil wir da vor drei jahren
unser haus gebaut haben habe probiert
wird das elektrisch zu machen ich habe
ziemlich viel vergessen von denen muss
man sagen also das sollte auf jeden fall
eine auffrischung ist dann nachher
mindestens ein danke auf jeden fall
alles gute für die zukunft und das war
es von uns von sportreporter wir freuen
uns wenn ihr beim nächsten mal wieder
mit dabei sein
[Musik]
[Applaus]